[Music]
welcome back
so in this lecture i'm really excited
about telling you
uh about how reinforcement learning
connects with optimal nonlinear control
this is just a splash screen don't try
to read everything i'm going to build
this out and go through it carefully i
just wanted to kind of show you this is
going to be a really cool one
and this fits in again to this bigger
picture of reinforcement learning that
we've been talking about specifically
[Music]
down here in this kind of model based
reinforcement learning where instead of
a probabilistic process we're dealing
with a nonlinear dynamical system or
differential equation x dot equals f of
x comma u
and we you know in the control boot camp
we talked a lot about how do you do
optimal control for linear systems when
these dynamics are given by a matrix a
times x plus b times u and this kind of
generalizes it to fully nonlinear
dynamics
okay and again this fits into this idea
that richard bellman put forward in the
50s
basically you can view this optimal
nonlinear control problem as part of a
broader class of optimization where you
can use ideas from dynamic programming
and this is bellman's equation that
we've seen before in reinforcement
learning we're going to see something
like that for these differential
equations so optimal nonlinear control
the idea is that we're going to be
working with this differential equation
so x is the state of my system it's a
vector of
information that characterizes the state
of my system like a pendulum on a cart
for example the position of the cart and
theta and theta dot the angle and
angular velocity of the pendulum
and f describes the kind of dynamics the
f equals m a dynamics of that system
and the goal is going to be to design
some control law u so u is something we
have control over we're going to design
a control law u to follow some
trajectory x of t that minimizes the
cost j
and that cost j is going to be given by
this cost function
and i'll walk you through this so this j
is a function of the trajectory x which
varies in time
the control u which varies in time
we say that this has a start time and an
end time t 0 and t final
and on the right hand side this cost
function is given by some kind of a
terminal cost
and you we usually include this to say
you know maybe i'm trying to get to some
final location
and if i don't quite get there there's
some cost associated with that so i want
to get to some final location
and maybe i also can penalize how long
it takes me maybe i have a term that is
you know a cost proportional to the
final time tf something like that and
then this term here is the amount
that that you increase the cost at every
little time step along the way so you're
going from state x at time 0 to exit
time tf
and at each step along the way there is
some cost associated uh with typically
with being far away from your state so
usually my goal minus x at time now
uh and also there is usually a cost
associated with using that control input
u maybe that you're actually burning
gasoline and it costs money okay
and again this could simplify in the
case of linear dynamics and a linear
quadratic regulator cost function
this might be just uh x
transposed times x so kind of x squared
plus u squared we might just measure
kind of the
uh the square
sum of errors of x minus its goal state
and of the control input u in which case
this would reduce to a linear quadratic
regulator problem if the dynamics were
linear
and so what we can do is essentially
introduce this value function just like
in reinforcement learning before
this value function is essentially the
cost j
when we have minimized over the control
input u so basically out of all of the
possible control functions u of t you
could you could pick
which is an infinite dimensional
function space
of functions u
if we minimized over all of those
controllers then the minimum possible
cost the best possible thing we could do
to get this minimal cost
that would be defined by this value
function
and it no longer is a function of u
because u is specified it's also not a
function of x of t because that is also
specified by u and by the dynamics it's
only a function of my initial condition
and my start and end time
and this value function is sometimes
called the cost to go and i'll come back
to that in a minute
and so what uh what bellman did and this
is a big deal so so bellman essentially
generalized the hamilton jacobi equation
for optimization if we didn't have u of
t here if we just had a free system
and we were trying to
for example find the minimum time
solution of a differential equation or
the minimum distance solution or things
like that then the hamilton jacobi
equations would be useful
those actually generalize some ideas
that bernoulli came up with from the
variation
the calculus of variations to solve
things like the
brachistochrone problem um the you know
finite
time problem or minimum time problem
and what uh bellman did was essentially
write down this partial differential
equation that has to be true for these
optimal solutions uh given by this
optimal u
and we're going to derive this this is a
little bit hairy so if this doesn't look
obvious it's not
and we call this the hamilton jacobi
belmont equation so the hamilton jacobi
equation you know was around for
a couple of hundred years maybe 150
years earlier
and again generalized
bernoulli's calculus of variations
and bellman came along and basically
extended it to include systems with
control inputs u of t okay so this is a
big deal this is one of the biggest most
important equations in uh nonlinear
control theory is this hamilton jacobi
bellman equation
and so just to recap the idea is that
this value function
is the cost given that we have optimized
to find the best possible control input
u of t
and the best u of t sometimes is a
function of x you might you know in a
linear quadratic regulator it would be a
function of x
uh defined that way
so we're going to actually derive this
and show where this comes from
and uh and also talk about how this
partial differential equation is is what
you actually need to solve
for for finding that that optimization
that that optimal control u because this
has to be true
for the optimal uh
minimum
solution u you can use this to actually
solve for you
good and this all relies on on bellman's
principle of optimality so this has been
something we looked at before in
reinforcement learning and we're going
to look at it
again for for this problem
so the idea here is that the value
function this this cost to go from time
0 to time tf
can be written as the sum
of the value function on any two
segments that make up that trajectory so
if i pick some intermediate point along
this trajectory x of t at any
intermediate time t
then i can add up the the value function
from t 0 to t
and the value function from t to t f
and that
sum is given is the value function
across this entire trajectory
and what that means is that at any point
t along this trajectory the remainder of
my trajectory still has to be optimal if
i imagine that my problem just started
over with this new initial condition x
of t at any point along this trajectory
it still has to be optimal as if i
started from that initial condition
every decision i make in the future
still has to be optimal
and so that's a really important idea
this bellman optimality
means that we can break this problem up
and essentially solve uh this
optimization using kind of smaller
optimization problems exactly like what
we did in dynamic programming for uh
reinforcement learning before okay
really important so we're going to use
this to derive the hjb equation
and again what we're going to do is take
this value function
and essentially expand it out we're
going to take the total derivative in
time and we're going to expand that out
so that's the partial of v with respect
to time
plus the derivative of v with respect to
the state x times
dx dt so this is how you do that kind of
total derivative
and we'll notice that uh dx dt is going
to be our dynamics x dot equals f of x
comma u
okay
and so
this expression here essentially what
we're going to do
is
this expression on the left is just d dt
of my definition of v
and so this is my definition of v here
where what i've done is i've put the d
dt inside the minimization because i'm
minimizing over over u of t
i can kind of swap those two those two
terms
and so if i take ddt of this integral i
should just recover uh i should just
recover my my integral
whatever is inside the integral because
this is a definite integral from 0 to tf
this
terminal cost kind of is fixed
and so what we're going to get is
is minus the argument l
of x t u t okay so that's that's what
this is going to equal when we take its
derivative
and uh and then we're going to minimize
that over uh all u's
and so essentially what i can do is i
can take this expression here and this
expression here and i can equate the
pieces so i'm going to move things
around and get a minus partial v partial
t
equals um kind of all of
this stuff here that's this minimum uh l
plus this partial v partial x transpose
times x dot
which is this term here
okay and i can you know this term here
because x dot equals
f of x comma u i can put that inside of
this minimization over u so i have to
put this inside the min of u because now
i've replaced my x dot with f of x comma
u
so that was a little fast you should
really kind of carefully convince
yourself that this is true
and in fact there's actually you know a
couple of pieces i glossed over a little
bit this is not the most precise way of
deriving this possible
the best way to do this is using the
calculus of variations this is kind of a
sketch of why this works um
and you know i think that this step from
here to here you'll really want to
convince yourself of why i could drop
these bounds of integration and when i
take the derivative with respect to time
uh why why this works out the way it
does okay
good and so that is kind of how you
derive this this hamilton jacobi belmont
equation
now the idea is that this is a partial
differential equation it's a partial
differential equation because v
is a function of t and of x and so you
can take its partial derivative so this
is a big partial differential equation
and we generally can solve this partial
differential equation
for v and then once we have v we can
extract u from it okay
and uh to some extent the way we
generally do this is using a two point
uh this is a two point boundary value
problem because we know uh what our
final state is where we wanna be
and so we can kind of and we know our
initial condition is and so you can use
like shooting methods or other
approaches to solve this two-point
boundary value problem
good uh okay so that was the continuous
time hjb i'll show you just briefly how
to do the discrete time hjb when you
have discrete time dynamics
and in this case you can similarly write
the cost function as the sum of a bunch
of intermediate costs at each step plus
some final cost at the nth or last
time step so here we have discrete time
steps
and again this cost function is defined
starting with an initial condition a
control sequence and however many steps
and i'm going to take
and so similarly you can define this
value function
where it is the best possible cost ji
could possibly have if i optimized over
that control sequence u
and again the bellman optimality the
kind of discrete hjp equation or bellman
equation here states that again the n
step value function the value function
starting from an initial condition
taking n steps
is the same as the sum
of the value function for any two
segments that kind of add up to that
full trajectory so if i start you know
if i go from from time step 0 to step k
that's this term here
that
if i started from x k
it should still be optimal in the future
meaning if i started from x k and i went
you know to that final n step it should
still be optimal uh going into the
future
good and i think here this this probably
should be an n minus k
and that can also be useful uh for these
equations
so then you can actually um
solve for sorry i think that was a
statement of bellman optimality um
i think this is a typo i think that i
should say that this is a statement of
bellman's optimality condition
and this is
going to be the
the discrete hjb equation right here
so again you can kind of represent this
as the minimum over all of the control
sequences of those intermediate costs
at the current step
xk
plus the value function at the next step
because of the bellman optimality
essentially what i have to do is i only
have to optimize my cost at the current
kth time step i only have to optimize my
control right now
so that if i step to the next step
through these dynamics if i go to xk
plus one
you know this
v k plus 1
is
is also minimized so let me say this
again what i'm trying to do
and my my parentheses are completely
botched here i apologize the parentheses
should be
the minimum of u should be outside of
these parentheses so what i'm doing is
i'm picking the best u at the kth time
step right now
so that
the current cost
plus my future value function at the
next time step is minimized
and again this is a statement of
bellman's optimality that i can break
this up into a recursion where the value
function at the step now
can be written in terms of the cost now
plus the value function at the next time
step and this allows me to do this kind
of recursive or iterative optimization
to solve for this and again there's a
lot of numerical methods this is a huge
field i'm showing you how these are
derived and what they are there's a huge
field actually showing how to solve
these
and they're they're very expensive i
should point out um
this is important when i derived the hjb
here for continuous time systems i said
that this is a partial differential
equation
and what that means if my original
dynamics x dot equals f of x comma u if
my original system had three discrete
states x1 x2 x3
this is a three-dimensional partial
differential equation that's very
expensive to solve if i have a 10
dimensional state i have a 10
dimensional pde if i have a thousand
dimensional state i have a thousand
dimensional pde and we're you know it's
pretty expensive to solve a thousand
dimensional pde
so these are really expensive to solve
you actually can find an optimal
nonlinear control solution but it
requires solving this kind of heinous
pde in high dimensions and that's really
really challenging numerically
okay so that's important similarly you
can do this for hjb and this is a better
way of writing it recursively where i
actually was
correct and pulled the minimization out
this is again for discrete hjb
and the idea again is that once you have
this expression here this kind of
bellman optimality expression
this starts to look a lot like what we
had from reinforcement learning so if
you minimize this expression over u you
get the um
the value function at that point and if
you do the argument if you find the u
that minimizes this you have extracted a
control policy this would be the optimal
control u equals pi of x
okay that was kind of a whirlwind a
little bit
high level but what i want to show what
i hope to show you is that
these ideas from dynamic programming and
reinforcement learning also connect very
strongly with optimal non-linear control
which is kind of a generalization of
what i've shown you before in the
control boot camp for linear systems
like lqr controllers
okay good so that's this piece here and
i'll probably have more lectures on kind
of non-linear optimal control maybe more
from a non-linear control perspective
and less from a reinforcement learning
dynamic programming perspective
but i hope that gives you kind of a
flavor of how these things fit together
all right thank you